all right so the mower fishing
expedition is now on day 561 and out
desperate for dirt any dirt on Donald
Trump
they are frenetic they're going to the
well 70 hours Michael Cohen apparently
spent with a special prosecutor one time
Trump attorney pled guilty to a charge
of lying to Congress over something
called the Moscow project now Cohen is
now claiming that the Trump Organization
continued to negotiate the finance by
Russia named lease of Trump deal of a
potential building in Russia during the
2016 election he first said discussions
had ended in January in 2016 now he's
saying they ended in June of 2016 the
destroyed Trump media of course used
these anonymous sources they're saying
the cone get this allegedly told
investigators he was negotiating a deal
in Moscow - maybe gift Vladimir Putin a
50 million dollar penthouse in the
proposed building project that Donald
Trump wasn't paying for so that rich
Russian oligarchs would want to live
there and just moments ago John Roberts
reported a source close to the president
calling it quote nuts it would be a
stupid idea and the president never
heard of any such deal and by the way
this deal guess what it never ever ever
happened the project never got off the
ground
no Trump Organization investments were
ever made and today the Trump
Organization has no buildings in Russia
it wouldn't know what if you were
watching the mainstream media there's by
the way even if it had happened this is
the most fascinating part there's no
crime here
none whatsoever Donald Trump was a real
estate mogul in New York that's what he
did is whole adult life and how we made
a living and he invested in many other
countries by the way doesn't every
politician that gets paid with our money
don't they get paid when they're out
campaigning for the next election by us
and the 2017 this potential project was
widely reported everywhere by just about
every outlet fake news CNN ABC News so
did the hill almost every other news
network in other words we knew this this
is not a new story in any way is it a
new story it's been reported on it
however that doesn't matter to the left
and it certainly didn't matter to robert
muller he's more interested in making
the mainstream media bubble and fizz
like alka-seltzer and water and he's
just desperate all he wants to do every
day is mention Russia in some way in
tithing all these former KGB guys all
their intelligence people that he's
never bringing to the United States ever
under any circumstances just so he could
mention Russia fomenting breathless
reporting to give credibility to his
never win ending witch-hunt and by the
way robert muller is playing your media
with their bias and their hate of trump
just like a fiddle what's this it's
Shakespearean because somebody who said
he would take a bullet for donald trump
yeah is now pointing the gun at them
michael cohen could be the most single
most terrifying person for donald trump
the single most destructive person for
donald trump going forward is a good day
for donald trump to resign i really
believe that at the president's reaction
to michael coins the news about michael
cohen today was exactly what we as
prosecutors always hear from mob bosses
and drunken kingpins that is that the
cooperator is lying he's just saying
these things about me that aren't true
to get a lighter sentence and so this is
downplaying out exactly like a
significant complicated organized crime
prosecution would play out
everything is aiming right at the
president personally and that's got to
be very unsettling for them so the truth
is putting aside all the conspiratorial
reporting from people that say they're
fair balanced objective and they're not
your mainstream media even if Michael
cones timeline revelation was accurate
let's say it is you know that it wasn't
January it was June no crime was
committed ever it wouldn't be a crime
legal scholar Alan Dershowitz is gonna
join us in just a minute
summed it up perfectly take a look
almost all the indictments secured by
Muller have either been indictments at
people lying that is for committing
crimes that didn't occur before he was
appointed but occurred as the result of
his being appointed or finding financial
misconduct by people that are unrelated
to the President or unrelated to the
Russia probes this new development with
Owen suggests the
they're gonna go after political issues
not just criminal issue Alan Dershowitz
is dead-on accurate by the way just
telling the truth and whatever happened
maybe I'm old-fashioned but I kind of
believed in attorney-client privilege if
if Cole was in fact working for the
Trump Organization as a lawyer
how could Muller and comb just break
what is a pretty ethical mandate
especially when there's no crime now of
course despite all of this there's no
evidence of Trump Russian collusion
nothing zero and today President Trump
he weighed in on the Cohn guilty verdict
with some pretty harsh words take a look
he's lying about a project that
everybody knew about I mean we were very
open with it we were thinking about
building a building I decided ultimately
not to do it there would have been
nothing wrong if I did do it if I did do
it there would have been nothing wrong
he's a weak person I'm not a very smart
person he's got himself a big prison set
and he's trying to get a much lesser
prison sentence by making up the story
now here's the thing even if he was
right it doesn't matter because I was
allowed to do whatever I wanted to in
the campaign and by the way to get to
this issue I called the Sammy the bull
Gravano while syndrome if you will how
prosecutors offer deals tell us this and
you got a get out of jail free card or
lower sentence lesser sentence now the
president's attorney Rudy Giuliani he
also waited and he said quote Michael
Cohen is lying it's no surprise the Cohn
lied to Congress he's a proven liar who
was doing everything he can to get out
of a long term prison sentence for
serious crimes of bank and tax fraud
that had nothing to do with the Trump
Organization look I know Michael Cohen
he has a wonderful family I can't I
can't imagine the pressure he's under
I'm not going to pile on he's got a lot
of hard things that he's facing but this
is important if this is Muller's big
witness it is fair to ask who are we to
believe the michael cone then or the
michael cone now that's a fair question
this is just the latest example of what
is Muller's concerted effort to turn the
screws on everyone who's ever associated
with president Trump let's look at the
list Michael Flynn no Russia collusion
he pled guilty to
lying to investigators they ruined his
life he had to sell his house and they
probably threatened his kid is my guess
George papadopolis he's spending two
weeks in jail nothing about Russia lying
to investigators he now will have a
felony on his track record forever Paul
man imported the book thrown over him
oh let's seek financial crimes dating
back to 2007 bank loan applications
taxes nothing
Russian nothing what's amazing is he had
a cooperation deal it ended likely
because well he wouldn't lie like jerome
corsi wouldn't lie meaning he's would
think about this Paul man afford tonight
is willing to risk dying in prison then
lie as the prosecutors would want jerome
corsi on this show last night on my
radio show for a full hour this
afternoon rejecting another lying
investigators plea deal he might die in
pretty 72 years old
he could have gotten to get out of jail
free card and now is under Muller's
microscope potentially facing life in
prison dying in prison like Paul
Manafort and as he said last night on my
radio show today he's willing to do that
because he can't lie before his God
that's what he said his faith won't let
him Roger stone is also literally
feeling the special counsels wrath now
none other man I just mentioned to you
had pled guilty to or admitted to
anything related to Russia collusion
there's no evidence of any Russia
collusion none of them are being tried
for any crimes related to collusion 561
days of what and here's the problem and
this is where we get to the crux of the
matter we have to analyze this deeply
what's happening is instead of seeking
truth and justice instead of applying
our laws in other words equally applying
our laws to everybody equal justice
under the law what you're watching is a
special council that has spun out of
control
left way beyond his mandate laying just
perjury traps and literally trying to
coerce people into what we call test out
lying
in other words Muller is telling people
if you just say what we want
I mean course he gave me full detail on
my radio show today look they were
saying just tell us and listen
probably won't even get probation you
know if not you're gonna die in jail
that's the choice and to think he's
saying I'm not gonna lie I won't lie I
believe in God Jesus I'm not gonna do it
it's similar prosecutorial treatment
that remember Sammy the bull Gravano you
may not remember the case I'll remind
you killed at least get this that guy
right there killed at least 19 people
got off no jail time then he just had to
literally testify against John Gotti and
then after that he was rewarded not only
did he not go to jail he was in the
witness protection program and he got a
nice new house in Arizona isn't that
nice
nineteen people no time in jail
meanwhile if you're not a notorious
gangster or a Trump ally the wheels of
justice are turning much differently
Muller's team collects lying to
investigators please like they're going
out of style
they can't get the underlying crime or
these people to say things that they
don't believe to be true top Democrats
deep state bureaucrats they lie they get
away scot-free I've got the list look at
the longtime Clinton aide Cheryl Mills
uma Abadie blatantly lied when they told
investigators that they had no knowledge
of Hillary's private email really
because they actually emailed there our
friend and reporter here at the Fox News
Channel special report catherine
herridge reporting either DOJ official
Bruce or or fusion GPS founder Glenn
Simpson likely lied due to their
contradictory testimony dirty dossier
author Christopher Steele not only did
he lie he lied in leaked and was fired
by the FBI and then guess what he was
working still with Bruce or fourth most
powerful guy at the Justice Department
and now we have notes that show that he
was trying to feed Bruce or whose wife
Ellie worked for fusion Nellie worked
for fusion GPS information he was trying
to feed Robert Muller and meanwhile
remember Steele doesn't even stand by
his own dossier when challenged in an
interrogatory in Great Britain James
clapper let's go to the videotape
he lied under oath about national
surveillance programs so too did John
Brennan he also lied under oath about
leaking James Comey lied under oath when
he said the report about the Clinton
investigation and not been written
before she was interviewed lie Comey
second
and Andrew McCabe he was actually fired
because of his pattern of lie
where are the federal cases against
these Liars against these people lying
to Congress instead what we're pushing
for charges fired at the eye director
Comey actually defended the do J's
pattern of lying on the view literally
saying I lie McCabe lied but you can
still be a good person if you lie well
unless you're a Republican then they're
gonna put you in jail you're second in
McCann McCain commands McCabe was fired
for lying multiple times within the FBI
you defended his character on Twitter
that's that's okay lying is okay
internally no it's definitely not in
fact the McCain case illustrates what an
organization that's committed to the
truth looks like we investigated hold I
ordered that investigation we
investigate and hold people accountable
good people lie I lay out on the book I
think I'm a good person where I've lied
I still believe Andrew McCabe is a good
person but the Inspector General found
that he lied and there's severe
consequences in the Justice Department
for lying as there should be throughout
the government the good people they lie
the only problem is if you're not giving
Muller what he wants oh then you're
going to be charged with perjury it's
what I've been telling you you want real
Russia collusion we've got it with all
the evidence that Muller doesn't have
about Trump we got the fixed email
investigation violation of the Espionage
Act the biggest obstruction of justice
case I've ever seen the dirty dossier
bought and paid for by Hillary Clinton
in the DNC why to light of voters and
convinced voters of Russian hookers
urinating in Trump's bed in Moscow so
that they won't vote for him I wonder
how many Americans didn't vote for Trump
because of that leaked lie that paid for
lie the FISA fraud abuse lying to FISA
judges literally a FISA fraud
extravaganza and of course omissions
that didn't even tell the judges that
Hillary paid for it and we got insurance
policies leaking policies is Robert
Muller even going to ever look in that
direction I thought we were looking for
the truth for real Russia collusion
we've got evidence on all of this and
it's a slam-dunk case why is he not
because there's one set of rules in this
country now
for one group of Americans the swamp
creatures or if you're a liberal
Democrat or your name's Clinton another
set of rules for everyone else try this
at home
you're subpoenaed you delete the email
subpoenaed you acid-wash your hard drive
you have your devices busted and you
have SIM cards taken out good luck to
you it's not going to work in other
words we don't have equal application of
the law equal justice under the law this
is a two-tier justice system you as an
American every American tonight it
should scare the hell out of you if the
President of the United States and those
who surround him are subject to what is
now clearly a double standard political
persecution nobody in this country is
safe nobody this is the United States of
America we're not a Banana Republic at
least we're not supposed to be this is
not how our constitutional republic and
system of justice is supposed to work we
can do better we better do better we
better demand better well have more on
this throughout the show but first we do
turn to a network whose motto is well
about as fake as their coverage the
so-called
facts first Network CNN forced to fire
longtime contributor today mark Lamont
Hill but only after widespread outcry
over his anti-semitic rant during a
speech at the UN take a look at this if
we are standing in solidarity
Palestinian people we must recognize the
right of an occupied people to defend
itself we must prioritize peace we must
but we must not romanticize or fetishize
it commit to political action grassroots
action local action an international
action that will give us what justice
requires and that is a free Palestine
from the river to the sea in case you
don't know from the river to the sea
Israel is located between the Jordan
River and the Mediterranean Marc Lamont
Hill was literally repeating a call from
terrorists and Palestinian extremists in
other words you'll wipe Israel off the
map
now while Hill was ultimately fired
literally disgusting far
rhetoric from CNN anchors contributors
had nothing new their hatred for the
president everything that he represents
the fact that he won has driven this
network into a very dark frankly scary
place
day after day minute after minute second
by second the coverage is more and more
absurd biased and frankly hateful we're
gonna show you a montage tonight you'll
want to show your friends